hi oh yeah gotta go if you want me to
drive you we gotta go no I want personal
chauffeur go it's okay
seriously dad walking would have been
fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day
against spider-man this guy swings in
once the day's zip steps up Nancy
you guys don't cops run red lights well
some do but uh not your dad in your
universe there's only one spider-man but
there's another universe it looks this
sounds like yours but it's not my name
is Miles Morales
thank you you like me
I knew my day would come around this
time I know it's complicated
wanna know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man mmm I love
this burger so delicious one of the best
burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about saving
the world you have to think about saving
one person one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
I see the spark in you it's amazing
paired up whatever you choose to do with
it you'll be great
I love you miles no dad I love you gotta
copy just like I talked when did you
teach me that I didn't it's a little
joke the team-building hey guys
okay who are you I'm Gwen Stacy my
spider people are there save us a Comic
Con
[Music]